[Music]
welcome everyone to the return of winter
wonderland I am Jeff from the overwatch
team we're super excited to tell you all
about the event and the return of the
event that's coming this December so
there's a lot coming I know one of your
favorite things to talk about whenever
we have a seasonal event is new skins
there's obviously going to be a lot of
legendary skins I don't want to reveal
them all I want to leave some surprise
for you when you log into the game but I
can tell you a long-awaited hanzo skin
that you've seen before maybe in one of
our comics is coming to light and we
think it's pretty awesome so that should
be really cool two of our favorite
junkers know no question who they are
we'll also be getting legendary skins
but don't fall into despair there are
other Legendary's coming besides the
ones that I mentioned we also did a
seasonal pass to some of our Maps as you
guys remember in past years we did a
seasonal pass to Kings row and to Han
amaura
those will be returning for the holiday
season but we've also done a seasonal
pass on the Black Forest arena map I
think it's one of the most gorgeous jobs
that our environmental artists have ever
done I was absolutely blown away when I
saw the work that they had done and we
really hope that you enjoy that speaking
of the Black Forest map we've taken Mays
global snowball Offensive and we've
moved it into the Black Forest you can
still play it in Antarctica as well but
it will now be available in the Black
Forest as well now we know how much you
all love May and you love events
centered around May during winter
wonderland so for this year's winter
wonderland there will be a new event
featuring yes you guessed it May and
it's called May's Yeti hunt so we really
want to try something different and fun
for this year's event and it's the idea
of what we call a boss fight so you're
gonna play one
team is going to be six maze it sounds
like everybody's worst nightmare and no
limits right six maze coming at you
against one single Yeti also known as
Winston sometimes so it's not a very
fair fight and the fact that it's six v1
now the Yeti is actually played by
another player it's not AI controlled so
when you cue up you'll have the
opportunity to pick I prefer to play as
May or I prefer to play as the Yeti
obviously the way the numbers work out
not everybody can always be the Yeti so
sometimes you're gonna say I prefer to
play as the Yeti and end up as May but
if you stay in long enough you will
eventually get to play as Winston the
mode is really fun and different takes
place in Nepal village it's spooky at
first where the team of maze is actually
trying to find Winston and what Winston
is doing is going around the map looking
for power-ups which are meat that fuels
his primal rage if he gets enough of
that meat he will go into primal rage
mode and then the tables turn
once Winston is primal raged the mages
have to escape they can use their ice
walls Mei has a special ability in this
mode where she can put down an ice trap
and basically the idea is get away from
Winston at all costs if enough of the
maze die then the the mode is over and
Winston wins if Winston dies then the
maze wins so we think it's a really fun
mode I think I said earlier that it was
it was six maze versus Winston is
actually five maze and the reason we did
that is if you want to queue up as a
group of six and just cycle the mode
with a different random player switching
into the Winston role you can do that as
well so we think this new mode is going
to be a lot of fun now I know a lot of
you are thinking it sounds kind of silly
and kind of ridiculous and well I'm here
to tell you it absolutely is but the
point of some of these seasonal brawls
are just to be fun and light and
refreshing for a short period of time we
know that the this mode is not going to
last
you know hundreds of hours and be highly
competitive we don't think Oh WL is
going to suddenly adopt may Yeti hunt as
their new mode and start playing that or
anything ridiculous like that this is
just a fun light-hearted way to play in
the arcade blow off some steam earn some
loot boxes and have some fun so we hope
you enjoy all of the content coming for
winter wonderland we had so much fun
making it and we really wish you the
best holiday season thank you so much
[Music]